welcome back uh where we left off in the
last video i had just purchased a
million dollar house to do it i went to
the bank and i said bank
can you give me 750 000 and they said
sure sal you have an excellent credit
rating and you look like an all-around
great guy so we'll give you seven
hundred fifty thousand dollars and so i
took that seven hundred fifty thousand
dollars and the two hundred fifty
thousand dollars that i had saved up
through through a lifetime of hard work
and i went and i bought that house so
after that transaction this is what my
my personal um well this might not
involve everything but this could be my
personal balance sheet but it looks like
my whole world is this house which in a
lot of cases it is for a lot of people
so in this situation what are my assets
i have a million dollar house on my
balance sheet i have one asset in the
world
you know i guess you can't quantify
charisma in good looks so the only real
tangible asset i have is a million
dollar house and what are my liabilities
well i owe 750 000
uh to the bank and so we we learned in
the last video and and you shouldn't
review this as a formula it almost it
should start to make a little bit of
intuitive sense that assets
are equal to liability plus equity
or the other way to view it is asset
minus liabilities is equal to equity
right to subtract the liabilities from
both sides
and you know that well if i have a
million dollar assets i owe 750 000 if i
were to resolve everything what i'd have
left over at the end is 250 000
and i could make that happen i could
sell the house for a million dollars
hopefully and then pay the bank back and
i would have 250 000 left so that's what
equity is just what you have left after
you resolve everything
or another way i mean this makes sense
to you if you talk about all of the
things you own minus all the things you
owe to other people equity is what's
left over or that could be owner's
equity so now let's play with um
some scenarios of uh
of of what happens maybe when the price
when the the value the market value of
the house changes
so let's say what happens when uh oh and
one one important thing to notice note
this this bank they're not just going to
give me 750 000 you know just to do
anything with it they're not going to
say hey sal here's 750 thousand dollars
i know you'll pay it back to me but you
can go gamble it in monaco they they
want to know that they have a good
chance of getting at least the money
that they they give the loan amount and
that's all
often referred to as the principal they
want to know that they're going to be
able to get that principal back one day
so what they say is sal we're only going
to give you this loan but this loan has
to be backed or it has to be
collateralized by some asset
and so what i say is okay well you know
i'm i'm taking this loan out to buy a
house this you know million dollar house
if for whatever reason i lose my job or
you know i disappear somehow or whatever
happens
if if i can't pay you the 750 000
you get the house
you'll get this million dollar house and
right now that looks like a pretty good
deal to the bank right they almost hope
that i'll default because they gave me
750 000
if after a day i just say you know what
bank i can't pay this loan i i don't
have the income or i lost my job i can't
afford the mortgage they get a million
dollar house overnight they would have
made 250 000 right they would
essentially gotten all my my equity for
free so in that situation uh the bank
works out pretty good and that's why
they make sure that there's something
that they can grab onto if you can't pay
the loan and that's why back in the good
old days and i think the good old days
are going to come back again and i think
they already are that the bank wants you
to put some down payment in a house
because there's a situation where let's
say that i do this i borrow the money
and i i buy the house um and i lose my
job or you know whatever i just drink
away all of my money
whatever the case may be
and so the bank and and they foreclose
foreclose means that sal isn't paying on
his paying his debt so we're going to
take the collateral back that he gave
for the loan so in that situation the
bank says sal can't pay we're taking
that house well when they take that
house there's a situation where
you know maybe they're not going to get
a million dollars for that house they
don't want to sit and wait for months
and months and months while a real
estate agent tries to sell it so that
the bank might just auction off the
house and when it auctions off the house
actually i think there are laws that it
can't get more than the mortgage or
anything more than the mortgage it gets
it actually has to pay taxes or we won't
go into all of that but it'll auction
off the house and maybe can only auction
off the house for eight hundred thousand
dollars
right so the million dollar asset would
really become an 800 000 asset and so
the bank keeps this equity cushion
right that if if if they loan 750 000
for a million dollar house and then the
million dollar house only sells for 800
the bank still gets all of their money
back
that's why in the good old days the
banks want you to put 20 or 25 percent
down because they know even if the how
how the value of the house drops
by 20 or 25 percent
it'll all come from your equity
and maybe i should draw a diagram to see
that situation let's say
let's say that for whatever reason
i have to sell this house in a fire sale
or let's say i can't sell the house and
the bank is forcing me to liquidate my
assets the bank says well then i want
that house back
so in that situation well actually
that's not a good situation because the
bank will just i'll just get wiped out
let's just do the situation where let's
say a neighbor's house sells for
a neighbor's house that is identical an
identical neighbor's house sells for 800
dollars right
so in that situation if i want to be
honest with myself and if i want to be
honest with the balance sheet and actual
you know real companies have to do this
i'll say you know what this asset i have
to revalue it i cannot
in all honesty say that this is now
worth this is a one million dollar asset
so i would revalue the asset and this is
actually called marking to market you've
probably heard of the heard this concept
marking the market means i have an asset
and every now and then maybe every few
months every quarter a quarter is just a
fourth of a year i have to figure out
what that asset is worth and the best
way to figure out what that asset is
worth is to see what identical assets
like that are going for in the market
and very few houses are completely
identical well there are in kind of a
few suburbs but very few assets are
completely identical but let's just say
that i know for a fact that an identical
house just sold for eight hundred
thousand dollars
so i have to be honest and i have to
market to market and then say that my
assets are now
an eight hundred thousand dollar house
eight hundred thousand house my same
house nothing really happened
but the market value has dropped by two
hundred thousand dollars for whatever
reason maybe maybe the car factory
nearby has has gone out of business
so in this situation what happens what
is my new balance sheet well has my
liabilities changed because my
neighbor's house sold for less well no i
still owe as far as the bank is
concerned i still owe 750 000 to the
bank
i still owe seven hundred fifty thousand
this is a liability i still owe seven
hundred fifty thousand dollars this is
assets of course so what's my leftover
what's what would be the leftover if i
were to liquidate at the market price if
i were to sell the house at the market
price well i would have 50k left over
so my
essentially when the market price of my
asset dropped
all of that value
came out of my equity
right and this is i'll do actually a
whole other video on on the benefits and
the risks of leverage because that's
very relevant to what's happening in the
world world today
but i think you get a sense uh what's
happening equity kind of takes all of
the risk
so in this situation
this is why the bank wants you to put
some down payment because the bank if
you can't pay this loan right here
they're going to take your house and
even in the situation where the value of
the house went down if you can't pay the
loan the bank will still be able to get
it's 750k right if you just
if you just leave town or lose your job
and you just tell the bank i can't pay
anymore they're just going to take this
house sell it hopefully for 800k because
that's what your neighbor sold it for
and they're going to get the money back
for their loan so that's why the bank
wants you to put
some down payment and then there's the
other situation which is maybe you know
a more positive situation and this is
what happened in much of a much of the
world and especially in areas like
california and and florida and nevada
over the last
five years or so and i'll do a whole
video on why it happened
but let's say your neighbor's house a
year later didn't sell for eight hundred
thousand dollars let's say the identical
neighbor's house sold for 1.5
million dollars and you say g-whiz
that's great now my house is also worth
for 1.5 million because i'm marking to
market
so now my asset nothing has really
changed it's still the same house but i
guess since someone else sold it for 1.5
million i guess i could too so my asset
is now 1.5 million dollar house
what are my liabilities well your
liabilities still haven't changed
i still owe
i still owe 750 000
700 that says 750 thousand dollars to
bank this is liabilities
so what's left over what's my equity
what's my equity
well assets minus liabilities so i have
750 000 of equity that's awesome even
though the house appreciated by 50 right
it went from a million to 1.5
my equity
grew threefold it it appreciated by it
appreciated by 200
and this is i think you're starting to
get the benefits of you know what what
happens when you do leverage leverage is
when you use debt to buy an asset
but when you use leverage your the value
of your the return that you get on your
asset gets multiplied when you go to the
return on your equity hope i'm not
confusing you but in this situation all
of a sudden i have a ton of equity and
i'm running out of time but in the next
video i'm going to talk about how this
happened because you saw in a lot of
neighborhoods a lot of housing a lot of
houses appreciated or the last
from about 2001 to 2005 and people all
of a sudden just sitting on their house
ended up with a lot of equity and they
felt that wow i just went from having
250 000 net wealth to 750 000 of wealth
without doing anything just by my
neighbor's house selling for more i'll
see in the next video